اهلا بكم بعد ايام قليله من سيطره
الحوثيين على العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء اصدر
تنظيم القاعده في جزيره العرب بيانا يتوعد
فيه الحوثيين بحرب شعوه ويدعو السنه الى
الكفاح وحمل السلاح للحلول
دون ما وصفه تكرار تجربه العراق في اليمن
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما دلاله دخول تنظيم القاعده على
خط المواجهه ضد الحوثيين بعد سيطرتهم على
صنعاء وما تاثير المواجهه بين الحوثيين
والقاعده على مستقبل اليمن
وخارطة باستهداف مسلحي جماعه الحوثي بعد
ايام قليله من سيطرتهم على العاصمه صنعاء
متهما اياهم باستكمال ما وصفه بالمشروع
الرافضي الفارسي في اليمن ودعى تنظيم
القاعده السنه الى توحيد الصفوف وحمل
السلاح وسلوك سبيل الكفاح ضد الحوثيين
وتنام
قوتهم يشتعل ليل صنعاء بالالعاب الناريه
احتفالا بما قال الحوثيون انه نصرهم لم
يقولوا انه نصر الهي لكن ن فوهات مدافعهم
قالت ما هو اكثر انها هنا تطل على صنعاء
وتحيط بها ولا باس وقد سقط النصر الالهي
من قاموسهم من استعاره شعارات اخرى شقيقه
الموت لامريكا الموت لاسرائيل في اجواءك
هذذه يوقع الرئيس اليمني اتفاق سلام قال
منتقده انه وثيقه استسلام ومنذ ذاك كما
يقول هؤلاء لم يعد الصراع سياسيا او مطلبي
ينتهي باسقاط حكومه تشكي اخرى بل اعاده
رسم خريطه المنطقه باسرها جيو سياسيا
انطلاقا من صنعاء الحوثيون اصبحت لهم
عمليا اليد الطوله هناك ما يمنح من
يوالونهم ارضا جديده في صراع المحاور في
هذه اللحظه نشعر بان هناك مؤامرات انها
المؤامره يقول رئيس هادي محذرا من حرب
اهليه ياتي هذا والحوثيون يقتحمون بيوت
القيادات العسكريه والسياسيه التي نصبت
العداء وهم يجردون صنعاء والدوله من
سلاحها وينقلونه الى مناطقهم فلا يبقى سوى
سلاحهم ما الذي
جرى بعض اليمنيين وصف الامر بالاحتلال
اخرون قالوا انها مؤامره شارك فيها الرئيس
المعزول علي عبد الله صالح واطراف اقليميه
لتصفيه الحساب مع الثوره التي اطاحت به
ومع القوى الاساسيه فيها واهمها التجمع
اليمني للاصلاح والخلاصه في راي هؤلاء ان
فضاء الصراع في اليمن لم يعد سياسيا بل
غدا مذهبيا او هو في صدد التحول الى ذلك
فسنه البلاد وفقا لاصحاب هذا الراي هم من
ضربوا على يد مشايعي مكون دون غيره لا
يخفي ارتباطاته الاقليميه تلك في راي
محللين هي الحاضنه التي تعيد تنظيم
القاعده الى الواجهه ولم يتاخر هؤلاء
كثيرا اصدروا بيانا يتوعد بنثر اشلاء
الحوثيين وجعل رؤوسهم تتطاير وليلهم نهارا
وصبحهم نارا فهم اي الحوثيون وفقا للقاعده
يستكملون ما سمته في بيانها المشروع
الرافضيه الفارسيه في اليمن والحل يكون
بحمل السنه للسلاح والكفاح والحذر من
تكرار تجربه اقرانهم في العراق القاعده
اذا تعود وهي التي لم تغب عن جنوب البلاد
منذ سنوات هناك ايضا حراك جنوبي وقبضه
ضعيفه للدوله ودعوات للانفصال وفي الشمال
حوثيون يحكمون قبضتهم ويتوسع وما بينهما
ما تبقى من بلاد وصفت يوما
بالسعيد موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع فواز جرجس
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه لندن
سيكون معنا من روما ومعنا ياسر الزعاتره
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من عمان وعبر
الهاتف من تعز معنا عبد الناصر المودع
الكاتب والباحث السياسي ابدا معك سيدي عبد
الناصر فيما يتعلق بهذا البيان الصادر من
تنظيم القاعده هل القاعده تستثمر في الوضع
الحالي في اليمن تحديدا في صنعاء ام ان
تاريخ العلاقه بين تنظيم القاعده وبين
الحوثيين ربما قد يفسر طبيعه ومضمون هذا
البيان
ا بيان القاعده امر متوقع
تماما فالقاع هي النقيض الموضوعي للحركه
الحوثيه وبالتالي هي ترغب او انها ا تريد
ان تستثمر هذا الوضع لتقوي من مواقعها
خاصه وان هناك اطراف من خصوم الحوثيين ا
سيوفرون للقاعده الحضن الاجتماعي
والجغرافي وال
السكاني لتقوم ويسهل لها لتقوم بضرب
الحوثيين خاصه وان القوى
السياسيه الكبيره والمنظمه
لازالت في حاله اقصد بها القوى التي يفترض
ان تعارض ولكن سيد عبد الناصر هل في تاريخ
العلاقه بين القاعده وبين الحوثيين نقاط
اشتباك نعم حدثت اكثر من من عمليه
اشتباك وبعض
العمليات ادعت القاعده انها انها قامت بها
وبعضها ادعى الحوثيون بان القاعده قامت
بها ضدهم
كما ان الخطاب
خطاب الحوثيون يتحدثون عن انهم يحاربون
التكفيريين وداعش
والقاعده ولهذا هم
يستدعون بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر القاعده
في المقابل القاعده خطابها خاصه في الفتره
الاخيره بعد ان تمكنت الحركه الحوثيه
وتمددت بشكل كبير اصبح الخطاب القاعده
تحول بشكل كبير طيب عن عن هذا الخطاب اسال
ضيفي الاستاذ ياسر الزعاتره عندما اطلعت
على هذا البيان بيان تنظيم القاعده في
تفكيك مفردات البيان هل تحمل اي دلالات
ربما تتجاوز الخطاب التقليدي المعروف عن
تنظيم
القاعده يعني ربما تتجاوز في بعض المفردات
الاكثر حده من الناحيه العمليه والتي تشبه
الى حد كبير مفردات تنظيم الدوله لكن من
الناحيه العمليه انا كتبت اول امس مقال
توقعت ان يتكرر السيناريو العراقي والسوري
هنا في اليمن وعلى نحو اكثر وضوحا وحده
هنا في في اليمن يعني حصلت اهانه لليمنيين
لثوره الشعب اليمني هذه ثوره ضد الثوره
تحالفت مع ال ال الرئيس المخلوع والخطاب
الايراني على هذا الصعيد كان بائسا ومثيرا
للاشمئزاز اذ يتحدث عن ثوره للشعب اليمني
هذه فئه لا تتجاوز 10% من الشعب اليمني
على شاكله الطائفه العلويه في سوريا ايران
تدمر التعايش في المنطقه ايران بمعول
الغرور والغطس تدمر التعايش في المنطقه
وتدخل معركه لن تنتصر بها في اي حال الذي
جرى في اليمن هو الذي جرى في العراق الان
لو لم تكن هناك قاعده في اليمن انا من
وجهه نظري حتى لو لم تكن هناك قاعده في
اليمن ستتابع او شكل من اشكال القاعده كما
كان تاسيس تنظيم التوحيد والجهاد الذي
تحول الى قاعده الجهاد في بلاد الرافدين
ثم الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق بسبب
الاحتلال الامريكي في العراق ثم عاد من
جديد بسبب الغطرسه الطائفيه لنوري المالكي
وبسبب التدمير الشامل في سوريا وبسبب
الغطرسه لبشار الاسد والدعم الايراني
لكليهما الان في في اليمن يتكرر ذات
السيناريو وبشكل اكثر وضوحا الان هناك
قاعده موجوده وهي ليس لا باس بقوتها لكنها
لم تتمك لم تكن تتمتع من الناح العمليه
باي حاضنه شعبيه تذكر هناك رفض في لما
تفعل القاعده ربما كان هناك رفض اخر
لسياسات الرئيس اليمني التي تقبل بنشاط
الطائرات من دون طيار و وترفض ال الحوار
مع القاعده الان هذه القاعده ستحصل على
حاضنه شعبيه وسينضم اليها كثيرون وربما
تظهر حركات مقاومه مسلحه ايضا تشتبك مع
الحوثيين ايران كما احرقت العلويين في في
معركه في سوريا لن تفضي الى نتيجه وفي
نهايه المطاف لن يعود الوضع الى ما كان
عليه قبل
الثوره في اليمن الان تدخل من اجل مشروعها
تدخل الحوثيين في محركه
اخرى فيما
يتعلق فيما يتعلق ببيان تنظيم القاعده
وهذه المقار التي اجراها مع الحاله
العراقيه بالاشاره الى الحاله العراقيه ما
دلالات هذا البعد في بيان القاعده فيما
يتعلق بالربط بين ما جرى في العراق والدور
ما سماه بالدور الفارسي تشكيل هذا الهلال
كما وصفه البيان ماذا عن هذا هذه المقاربه
بما يتعلق بالحاله
العراقيه يعني بالفعل لنضع العصبيه والحده
في الخطاب جانبا الان ونتكلم تحليليا يعني
لا اعتقد ان احدا يستغرب هذا
البيان لان الحاله اليمنيه الحققيه هي
يبدو انها تكرر الحاله العراقيه والسوريه
هل كان هناك من تنظيم للقاعده في العراق
قبل احتال احتلال العراق ب 2003 تدمير
الدوله والمؤسسات العراقيه انشاء نظام
محاصصه طائفيه سياسات تدميريه من قبل
الطاقم السياسي العراقي ا هذا هذه
السياسات تدمير الدوله الوطنيه بغض النظر
عن يعني النظام السلطوي
للرئيس الراحل صدام حسين هذه السياسات
الحقيقيه اوجدت حاضنه شعبيه وطبعا الصراع
في سوريا وانا لا اتحدث في ب الفاظ يعني
مذهبيه ابدا اخجل ان اتكلم بذلك ولكن صب
الزيت على النار ا يعني اعطى زخما لهذه
التنظيمات تنظيم القاعده بغض النظر
تنظيمات يعني داعش والنصره واخواتهم
تنظيمات عدميه يتغذون الحقيقه عن الانشطار
الاجتماعي عن الوضع المذهبي عن السياسات
السلطويه ا يسوقون انفسهم على انهم راس
الحربه يدافعون عن اهل السنه وطبعا اهل
السنه انهم اذكياء لا يدين لتنظيم القاعده
ان يدافع ولكن هناك شريحه مهمه من الشعوب
العربيه الحائيه تعتقد ان هذه التنظيمات
الحقيقيه هي تدافع عن وجودها وعن وعن
هيبتها وعن انسانيتها ومن ثم يلي الاسف
انا لا استغرب ولا وليس لدي اي شك ان
تنظيم القاعده في الجزيره العربيه سوف يجد
نوعا من الحاضنه الشعبيه كما وجد تنظيم
داعش دكتور فواز دكتور فواز باختصار هذه
الحاله هذه الوضعيه هل هي نتاج طبيعي
لتداعيات لواقع ام مساله يدفع باتجاهها
بشكل
متعمد لا انا انا لاكن صريحا انا لا اؤمن
بالنظريه بالمؤامره بيرد يعني ابدا هذه
كله كلام انا اعتقد انه تنظيمات الحرب
البارده حرب القوى
الاقليميه لديها تداعيات مذهبيه كما نعلم
انا اتكلم بصراحه الصراع بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايران ليس فقط ايران
وحدها في الساحه هذا الحقيقه يؤدي الى صب
الزيت على الوضع المذهبي النقطه الاولى ما
هي كيف يمكن ان نفسر هذه الظاهره انا لا
اعتقد انه هذا يعني هذا صراع مذهبي هذا
صراع سياسي ايديولوجي ليس هناك فرق بين
السنه
والشيعه اخير تفضل تفضل
بايجاز نقطه ما كيف يمكن ان نفسر هذه
الظاهره فشل الدوله الوطن
فشل مشروع التنميه سلطات سلطه سلطويه
تستخدم الدين وتستخدم العنف والاستبداد
والقهر وهذه ومن هنا الحقيقه يعني هذا
الانشطار الاجتماعي ومن هنا الحقيقه هذه
التنظيمات العدميه تجد حاضن انا فقط كنت
يض اشير بان هذه النقطه ماشتها قبل قليل
سوف نناقشه بشكل اكثر تفصيل في الجزء
الثان من ه الحلقه فيما يتعلق بالتداعيات
داخل اليمن وكذلك في بعدها الاقليمي استاذ
عبد الناصر مودع فيما يتعلق بالحاله
اليمنيه وهذه الث ثنائيه تنظيم القاعده من
جهه والحوثيين من جهه اخرى هل اليمن هل
المشهد اليمني فعلا اصبح الان يتلخص امام
هذه الثنائيه راس سني تعلوه القاعده وراس
شيعي تعلو يعلوه الحوثيين هل نحن الان
امام هذا
المشهد لا اعتقد ان المشهد بهذه الصوره
الواضحه على الاقل في الوقت
الحالي
القاعده صحيح انها لم تكن لديها حاضنه
شعبيه كبيره
قبل تمدد وال الحوثيون ووصولهم الى صنعاء
وسيطرتهم عليها ولكن يبقى امر مهم ان
اليمن لا يمكن تكرار تجربها
العراقيه السنه في العراق عندما احتضنوا
بشكل او باخر القاعده هم شكلوا اقليه
صغيره مقارنه
بالشيعه في اليمن الامر مختلف تماما
الحركه الحوثيه
مثل ما ذكر ضيفك من عمان لا يزيد على احسن
الافتراضات عدد او من يؤيدها عن 10% من
السكان وبالتالي البقيه من سيعرضها هم كثر
وهم اقوياء ولن يكونوا
بحاجه الى القاعده وبالتالي لن تكون
القاعده هي الاداه الرئيسيه في مواجهه
الحركه الحوثيه خاصه وفي حال تدخلت
العربيه السعوديه بكل تقلها لتدعم
المعارضين
للحوثيين فهي في هذه الحاله لم تسمح بان
يكون القاعده ضمن هؤلاء ولكن على الاقل في
المدى القصير
والمباشر كون القاعده هي جاهزه ولديها
الاستعداد وتريد ان تستغل هذا الوضع فمن
الممكن القول بانه في الفتره القري
القريبه القادمه ييمكن ان تكون القاعده هي
اكثر الاطراف
التي سيدخل في مواجهات مع الحركه الحوثيه
لهذه الاسباب التي ذكرت طيب فاصل قصير
بعده سنناقش تاثير المواجهه بين الحوثيين
والقاعده على مستقبل اليمن وكذلك خارطه
التحالفات في المنطقه ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش مستقبل اليمن على ضوء سيطره
الحوثيين على صنعاء واعلان تنظيم القاعده
الحربه ضدها اجدد تحيه بضيفي الاستاذ ياسر
الزعاتره وكذلك الدكتور فواز جرجس استاذ
ياسر زعت فيما يتعلق بتاثير ما يجري الان
في ظل تهديدات تنظيم القاعده للحوثيين على
لنبدا باليمن اولا قبل قليل استمعنا الى
الرئيس عبد الله بن منصور هذه يقول بان
اليمن والدوله لم تنهار وما زالت على
باتها ولكن في حال الدخول هذه الحاله بين
القاعده وبين الحوثيين الى مستوى متقدم
ماذا عن العمليه السياسيه وكل المخرجات
السياسيه في اليمن
برايك يعني اولا يعني تعليقا على كلام
الدكتور فواز توصيف الوضع الطائفي ليس
طائفيه ونحن لم نكن طائفيين يوما ايران هي
التي اعلنت الحرب المذهبيه في المنطقه دعك
من الكلام الدبلوماسي لكبار السياسيين
وتابع المواقع والصحف الايرانيه وبعض
المسؤولين العسكريين والامني وانظر كيف
يتحدثون عن ما يجري و وع ما جرى في اليمن
بالنسبه للوضع اليمني الداخلي من الصعب
الحديث عن تكرار حرفي للسيناريو العراقي
ليس هناك نموذج يتكرر بالحرف هناك ربما
خليط من الحاله العراقيه والسوريه مع شيء
من الخصوصيه للوضع اليمني ان كان على صعيد
الاغلبيه والاقليه هناك ممثله في الاقليه
الحوثيه مقابل الغالبيه اليمنيه التي شعرت
بالاهانه من تعاطي هؤلاء مع الوضع كقوه
احتلال كماما تماما كما يتعامل بشار الاسد
كقوه اح احتلال وبالتالي هذه الاهانه سيرد
عليها ال اليمنيون بطريقتهم لو لم تكن
القاعده لكانت اشكال اخرى من المقاومه
الذي يجري الان هذه الغطرسه الحوثيه
والتعاطي كما قلت كقوه الاحتلال سيرد عليه
بالطريقه المناسبه هذه اثبت فشله وهو ربما
كان جزءا من المؤامره وبالتالي الوضع
اليمني يدخل الان في مسار حرب اما ان يذهب
هؤلاء في اتجاه تسويه ويعيدوا السلاح الى
الدوله ويقبلوا بالانضباط في العمليه
السياسيه كقوه سياسيه عاديه يمكن ان تقبل
بالاحتكام الى صناديق الاقتراع اذا اصروا
على مسار القوه والاحتفاظ بالسلاح وفرض ان
يكرروا نموذج حزب الله في في لبنان بان
يفرضوا ما يريدون سياسيا من خلال التلويح
بالسلاح هذا لن يكون مقبولا وبالتالي
القاعده ستتحرك لكن التحرك الاكبر سيكون
من القوى السياسيه والمجتمع اليمني بناء
على مواقف الح الحوثيين التاليه المشهد
الاخر على مستوى المنطقه المشكله ان الذين
رعوا المبادره
ال الخليجيه والذين سرقوا من الناحيه
العمليه الثوره اليمنيه لانهم اصلا اولويت
السياسيه هي مطارده الثورات وربيع العرب
والاسلام السياسي السني وتحديدا حاله
الاخوان المسلمين على وجه التحديد
وبالتالي هؤلاء يرفعون شعار مواجهه ايران
من ناحيه لكن اولويته السياسيه التي
تستحوذ على عقولهم هي مساله الثورات وربيع
العرب لكن هذا لا يعني ان المشهد برمته
اصبح في حرب طائفيه مجنونه كان الوضع مشتك
بسبب العراق وبسبب سور ليس بهذه الحاله
استاذ ياس سؤالي موجه للدكتور فواز دخول
القاعده على الخط في المشهد اليمني وما
يعرفه من يه الانقال السياسي هل س سيزيد
الوضع ارتباكا برايك ام لا ربما قد يضبط
الايقاع في هذا البلد
المرتبك لا لا اعتقد ابدا ان سيعقد الامور
سيصب الزيت على النار يمكن انا لا اعتقد
ان الحاله اليمنيه هي نفس النموذج العراقي
ولكن سوف
يستخدم تنظيم القاعده في الجز الجزيره
العربيه هذه الاوضاع هذه الهجمه من قبل
يعني من قبل الشريحه الحوثيه التي تعتبر
الحقيقه ان تحدي للدوله
الوطنيه ويستخدمها بطريقه زقيه ويجد بعض
الحاضنه الشعبيه انا بكل صراحه يعني من
الاهم بمكان انه ان نزين الكلمات تبعنا
ونبتعد عن الخطاب الطائفي هذه مرحله دقيقه
في العالم العربي يعني كل كلمه لها معنى
معين الكلام عن الصراع السني الشيعي كلام
فاضي لا يعني اي شيء المسلم انا انا اسف
اتكلم بهذه الطريقه في الاسلام ليس هناك
من كنيسه كاثوليكيه وبروتستانت يعني انا
انا اتكلم ومن هنا اهميه التجديد على ان
هذا الصرا صرا وصراع سياسي فقط دكتور دكور
فقط حتى نستثمر في وقت البرنامج يعني فقط
لنبقى فيما يتعلق بموضوع هذه الحلقه
وتاثير دخول القاعده فيما يتعلق بالمشهد
اليمني وعن توقعات على الاقل على مستوى
اليمن في حد
ذاته طبعا يعني الوضع في اليمن هو الحقيقه
اليمن على شفير الهاويه انت عندك الحقيقه
فجوات فجوات مذهبيه مناطق يعني فجوات
سياسيه فجوات ايديولوجيه دعني اتكلم
الحقيقه ليس فقط عن اليمن عن الوضع العربي
ككل انا اعتقد ان المقاربه العسكريه هذا
التحالف الاقليمي والدولي المقاربه
العسكريه لن تعطي ثمارها طالما المقاربه
السياسيه والاجتماعيه مغيبه يعني ال ما
يجري في اليمن ما يجري في سوريا ما يجري
في العراق ما يجري في ليبيا ما يجري في في
السودان اهميه اعاده بناء الدوله الوطنيه
على اسس جديده قضيه اهميه التنميه الفقر
والقهر والاستبداد والاضطهاد هذا الصراع
الحقيقه ب على تفضل اشكر دكتور فواز استاذ
ياسر زعتره فيما يتعلق بتداعيات ما يجري
كما قلنا ودخول القاعده على الخط في
المشهد اليمني وتداعياته على المنطقه قبل
قليل كان معنا ضيفنا من صنعاء واشار الى
المتوقع من دور سعودي بحكم البعد
الاستراتيجي لليمن بالنسبه العربيه
السعوديه وكذلك دول الخليج دول المنطقه
ماذا عن هذا البعد وتاثره بربما ما يصدر
الان من بيانات من القاعده وما يجري على
الارض من تحرك للحوثيين
يعني بتقديري انه يعني يجب ان تتحرك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لصالح ترميم
الوضع اليمني بعيدا عن عقد الاسلام
السياسي ومطارده الثورات هذه خاصره
بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبعض
تجليات الخطاب السياسي الايراني في
المواقع والانترنت وفي حتى الصحف تتحدث عن
التهديد التالي او العاصمه ربما الخامسه
او الاجتياح الخامس بعد اربعه عواصم
العربيه يعتقد الايرانيون انهم سيطروا
عليها هذا صراع سياسي بامتياز لكن تستخ
يستخدم الغطاء المذهبي في سوريا نادى نصر
الله ونادت ايران بالحوار السياسي ونبذ
السلاح بينما احتفلوا باستخدام السلاح في
اليمن وبالتالي هناك حرب مذهبيه مدمره في
المنطقه شئنا ام ابينا هذه الحرب تاخذ
تجليات مذهبيه في العراق وفي سوريا وحت
وفي الى حد ما في لبنان وفي في اليمن الان
اذا لم تقبل ايران بك اذا لم تعد الى
رشدها وتتوقف عن غرور وغطرسته القوه وتقبل
بحجمها الطبيعي في المنطقه هذه معركه
ستخسرها بكل تاكيد لن تعلن الاقليه الحرب
على الاغلبيه في الامه ثم تربحها هذه امه
هزمت الاحتلال الامريكي في العراق ودمها
نازف منذ قرون وحاربت الاستعمار ولديها من
ادوات القوه ما تستطيع ان تهزم به اي شكل
من اشكال الاحتلال على ايران ان تفهم هذه
المعادله هناك ثلاثه محاور في المنطقه
العرب وتركيا وايران هناك قواسم مشتركه
يمكننا ان نتعايش على اساسها ليست المشكله
هي المذهبيه المشكله هي الاستخدام السياسي
للمذهب في سياق حروب لمشروع تمدد ايراني
مجنون ومتغطرس يريد ان يسيطر على الوضع في
المنطقه هذا لن يكون وجود مشار الاسد في
السلطه وبال الاصرار على وجوده لس هناك
الا هذه الحرب سؤالي مجه لدكتور فواز هل
نحن ايضا في الحاله اليمنيه قد نكون امام
نفس المخرجات بالنسبه لما جرى ويجري في
الحاله السوريه والحاله العراقيه وضع معين
تقلبات سياسيه تنتهي في النهايه بظهور
تنظيم على شاكله الدوله الاسلاميه او
تنظيم القاعده ف تحالف دولي ف عمليات هل
الحبل على الجرار والحاله تتكرر وكانها
صور
كربونيه اعتقد ان الحاله اليمنيه تختلف
نوعا ما لا اعتقد
يعني لان الحقيقه الشرائح اليمنيه تختلف
القاعده ليس لها لديها القوه في اليمن لان
هناك قوى سياسيه واجتماعيه وايديولوجية
هجمه اي تنظيم معين ولا اعتقد الحقيقه ان
العالم الخارجي مهتم باليمن باهتمامه
بالعراق ولكن اعيد تكرار الكلمه على يعني
على السطح هو صراع مذهبي ليس هناك من صراع
مذهبي في العالم العربي هذا صراع سياسي
اقليمي ايديولوجي يتغذى على قضيه المذهبيه
من الخطا بالمكان الحقيقه يعني التكرار
هذا الكلام قضيه الوعي الوعي الجمعي
للعالم العربي علينا مسؤوليه تاريخيه ان
نوصلها الى المستمع والمشاهد العربي ان
ليس صراع مذهبي في الاسلام هذا صراع
اجتماعي وسياسي واقليمي علينا ان نفرغ هذا
الصراع من يعني مفهومه الوجودي ومن ثم
ايران طبعا لديها سياسات ايران لديها
سياسات خاطئه للغايه اخطات بطريقه تدميريه
في العراق في سوريا ولكن لا يعني هذا صراع
مذهبي بين السنه والشيعيه اكرر هذه النقطه
صراع سياسي ايديولوجي اقليمي اشكرك دكتور
فواز جرجس استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه لندن كنت معنا من روما وكذلك اشكر
السيد ياسر زعتره الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
كنت معنا من
عمان بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
ه